[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN GALPIN: All right.
Welcome to "Migrating
Your Android App
to Android O and Beyond."
FRED CHUNG: Hi.
I'm Fred Chung,
developer advocate.
DAN GALPIN: Hi, I'm Dan
Galpin, developer advocate.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: Hi, I'm Eric,
not a developer advocate.
I'm the lead software engineer
responsible for migrating
the Google Play Store
app to target API 26.
DAN GALPIN: Thank you for
joining us on the afternoon
of the last day.
This is where they schedule
the most anticipated sessions,
except for that funny improv
one that we don't record.
Sorry, home viewers.
So you're here
for what is really
the grand finale of Google I/O.
FRED CHUNG: Well, let
the grand finale begin.
So, why migrate?
There are lots of reasons,
but foremost in your mind,
especially if you are
distributing on Google Play,
is that for new apps, by the end
of this year, in August 2018,
you must be targeting at least
API level 26, or Android 8.0.
Likewise, for app
updates, they must also
be targeting at least API
level 26 by November of 2018.
That is if you wish
to continue releasing
app updates going forward.
DAN GALPIN: Now, every
new Android version
introduces changes that
bring significant security
and performance improvements,
and enhance the experience
of Android overall.
Some of these changes only apply
to apps that explicitly declare
support through their target
SDK version manifest attribute,
also known as the
target API level.
In fact, if you try to
upload an APK with a target
SDK less than 26, you'll begin
to see a friendly reminder
like this.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: And
I'm here because we
wanted to keep updating the
Play Store app on Google Play
after the November deadline.
FRED CHUNG: So let's go
over some basics real quick,
everyone.
Minimum SDK is the
lowest platform version
your app is willing to support.
It's often the decision
tied to market penetration
of various Android releases.
DAN GALPIN: The compile
SDK is literally
the SDK headers and stub library
that your project links to.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: And the
important one, of course,
is the one I'm talking about.
The targetSdkVersion
is the platform's way
to ensure backwards
compatibility.
This means that you only
have certain behavior
changes applied as certain
specific target SDK versions.
FRED CHUNG: So, technically,
this needs to be true.
And this is the typical
and recommended case,
since you probably
care, about 95% of users
out there that are not
quite targeting the latest
versions of Androids
just yet, although we
are working to improve that.
DAN GALPIN: So if you
don't change your target
SDK to at least version
26, you might not
have to deal with things
like runtime permissions,
AlarmManager changes, coming
up with different ways
to handle
BroadcastReceiver actions,
and avoiding
background services.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: But
there's a good chance
that your app would waste
network and battery,
while making the device
experience less fast and fluid.
FRED CHUNG: So if you are
migrating from a pre-M version,
one of the bigger changes
is probably the support
for runtime permissions.
Runtime permissions are really
about user privacy and trust.
But it also allows for apps to
ask for sensitive permissions
in context.
And that's a good
thing for apps,
because you don't want someone
to not install your apps
just because you are
asking for permission
for some sensitive information
in one particular flow
within your app.
So, first of all,
not all permissions
are runtime ones, just this
simple, easy to remember this.
FRED CHUNG: But worry
not, developers.
You can think of the
permissions the way
the user sees them in terms
of these broader categories.
And the first question
you should have
is whether the app really
needs the provision at all.
After all, removing
the permission is easy.
Now, Eric, how did the
Play Store app handle this?
ERIC KUXHAUSEN:
Well, it's simple.
All you need to do is
make sure that your app
has pre-granted the permissions
on the system image.
FRED CHUNG: That's not
very helpful, Eric.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: That being
said, we, too, try and use
as few of these as possible.
DAN GALPIN: And, of course,
just because your app isn't yet
targeting M, it doesn't
mean that your users can't
go and disable any permissions
they don't want you to have.
FRED CHUNG: And there
are special permissions
that you need to redirect the
user to settings to obtain.
For example, drawing
overlay windows, or there
could be some
procession permissions
like screen capture.
DAN GALPIN: Now, being
the work of the UI,
runtime permissions actually
require an activity or fragment
that has overridden the
onRequestPermissionResult
method.
Now, this means that
your view layer,
like activities
and fragments, need
to anticipate any
permissions actually required
by the other layers.
All right, here's
a great transition.
Let's talk about alarms.
Alarms in Android
take two basic forms.
They are literal alarms that
allow an app to wake itself up
to deliver a notification
of some real-time event,
such as waking you up, or
an upcoming appointment.
Or they are a way
of scheduling work
to happen at some time in the
future after the app is closed.
And at the beginning of
Android, this was a single API.
But back in KitKat, we
made AlarmManager not exact
unless it was
explicitly requested,
which makes it better for
scheduling future work.
Now if an app needs to notify
the user at a precise time,
we added the method setExact.
And here's where
we've implemented
a method in the support library
to call it on KitKat and above.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: We don't use any
exact alarms in the Play Store
app.
The alarms we do
use are inexact,
which allows the system
to batch them for better
battery and system health.
DAN GALPIN: Now,
Android Marshmallow
added doze, which allowed
Android to go idle when
alarms would normally fire.
So we added the obvious method,
setExactAndAllowWhileIdle,
to allow alarms to awake
the device from doze.
And we've implemented a method
in the support library for that
as well.
And note that it actually calls
the previous support library
method for setExact on
earlier platform versions.
FRED CHUNG: So after
all that exposition,
so the takeaways are
pretty simple, right?
Consider moving future work
to GCM job via WorkManager.
WorkManager is the new
work scheduling thing
that we launched.
DAN GALPIN: Now WorkManager
is a part of Jetpack.
And it chooses the best
way to run your tasks
based upon things such as
API version and app state.
And when it becomes stable,
it will be the recommended API
for running tasks, unless
we come up with something
better before then.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: Play Store
was able to see our background
tasks regularly reach
2% more users on KitKat
when we adopted Firebase
JobDispatcher, rather than just
using alarms.
This improves system
health and battery usage.
If you do have to use alarms,
use the least exact ones
you can.
FRED CHUNG: Now, remember
that the most exact alarms,
like [INAUDIBLE],, should only
be used every 15 minutes or so.
So you should only be
using those judiciously.
DAN GALPIN: Oh,
yeah, WorkManager.
So let's talk again
about BroadcastReceiver.
FRED CHUNG: Should we talk
about BroadcastReceiver?
DAN GALPIN: We should
talk about them.
FRED CHUNG: Let's do that.
DAN GALPIN: Yes.
FRED CHUNG: So
BroadcastReceiver, I
think many of you
probably know that, right?
That's used by the platform
to notify and launch
apps in response to
system-wide events.
It's one of the reasons that
Android has such a powerful API
service.
DAN GALPIN: Now with great power
comes great responsibility.
And, in response to the
way that these end points
have been used, most of these
can no longer launch your app,
at least once you target O.
FRED CHUNG: Well, there
are exceptions, of course.
It's Android, right?
Many of these
happen very rarely,
such as changes in locale.
Or, in some cases, there are
just no alternatives just yet
to the broadcast for the apps
that need them, for example,
like those USB accessory ones.
Let's check an example on how
to avoid using broadcasts.
So for a job, you can do so by
setting up the proper execution
criteria, suggest
requiring network service,
and then we can
have functionality
that's comparable to listening
to network state change
broadcasts.
And if you do have code
like this in your manifest
on the older
versions of Android,
you can disable the listener
to the connectivity change,
and just leave it disabled.
And then, what are
you going to do?
You can then enable
the receiver by setting
the ComponentEnableSetting
in the PackageManager.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN:
Another exception
is if you need to perform many
tasks after your pack has been
updated, for example,
rescheduling alarms or updating
your database.
You can still
register a receiver
in your manifest for the
action_my_package_replaced,
which continues to
work, because it's
one of the explicit broadcasts
targeted just to your app.
DAN GALPIN: Now,
if you really need
to do some work in
every package update,
and you probably
don't, because you
can no longer be launched by
action_package_replace_events.
But we do have an API
called getChangedPackages,
which allows your
app to see what
packages have changed since the
previous saved sequence number.
Now, in life, running
is usually healthy.
I probably should do more.
But an Android app wants to
run as little as possible.
And lazy apps are
actually better apps.
And I should make a
manifesto or something.
Fred, what do you think
that we should actually--
FRED CHUNG: Sounds good to me.
First of all, let's
talk about what
it means to be in
the foreground,
because it's not
completely obvious, right?
There are some typical
cases, like when
your app is visible to
users, or when you're
using foreground service,
or if your app is
bound to a foreground app.
So your app is also
in the foreground
in these exceptional cases.
Your app is in the background
when you're not visible,
such as when it's running
a standard service, job
service, or BroadcastReceiver.
And when you're on O+.
Starting a service when
running in the background
will throw an exception
called IllegalStateException,
which is not good.
DAN GALPIN: Now you
can start services when
your app is in the foreground.
And they'll continue to
run for about a minute
after your app is backgrounded.
And this is
particularly important,
because on O, the
system releases
any wake locks
that your app holds
when you have no active
components, such as activities
or services.
And this applies to all apps,
not just apps targeting O.
FRED CHUNG: There are a few
cases where your app is still
allowed to run if
it's foreground
and start services, for example,
in response to notification
action, a high priority
Firebase Cloud message,
or in response to
MMS or SMS delivery.
So let's talk through
some solutions
for running in the background
without background services.
DAN GALPIN: First of all,
use GCM fire job-- ah!--
WorkManager for
background tasks.
Now there are very many
good reasons for this.
It creates a consistent API
service across many Android
versions, for example.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: Or if you
don't care as much about having
your app behave consistently
across platforms,
or want to move to O with the
least amount of work required,
you can also use
JobIntentService.
DAN GALPIN: But, seriously,
consider using WorkManager.
Leverage its constraints
and make your life easier.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: So the
Google Play Store app
didn't have the luxury
of using WorkManager,
because it didn't exist yet.
That meant we had to use
JobScheduler and Firebase
JobDispatcher.
Now, the first thing
we learned is not
to use JobScheduler
on Android L,
unless you really
understand how it
behaves, and have
alarm watchdogs when
it doesn't behave as expected.
Also, use workarounds.
For example, on L and
the first release of M,
JobScheduler won't
actually run your job,
unless there are two jobs
with the same constraints met.
You can work around this
by scheduling two jobs
with matching constraints.
DAN GALPIN: But, seriously,
like WorkManager.
FRED CHUNG: WorkManager.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: Things do get
much better for JobScheduler
on M, MR1, and above.
However, another
quirk is that you
should avoid calling set
minimum latency to zero.
This can interfere
with the override
deadline on some releases.
The override deadline
is a way of making sure
that your job runs with
a fixed period of time,
even if the
constraints aren't met.
DAN GALPIN: Or
you could just use
WorkManager, which
doesn't actually
have override deadlines.
But what you should do
is schedule a second job
as a watchdog to perform
a similar function.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: Here
are a few things
to consider when using
JobScheduler or WorkManager.
Android tries to detect captive
portal and [INAUDIBLE] never
conditions, but is
an imperfect art.
In addition, Android
will occasionally
wake up your app
right before network
is available to your app.
All this means is that you need
to have proper error handling
to ensure rescheduling of jobs.
When Play Store added
exponential backoff
to our jobs, we saw 19% more
successful background tasks.
The key here, though, is
let the system do its work.
It's easy to make the mistake of
rescheduling with the same job
ID, while also using
system backoffs.
This can interfere, or even
reset, the backoff rate.
DAN GALPIN: Or
with WorkManager--
actually, yeah,
don't do that either,
because it'll have
the same result.
FRED CHUNG: So for
APIs that require
that you use PendingIntents,
you can change the PendingIntent
targets from service
to a BroadcastReceiver.
Now, if your task will
execute within 30 seconds,
you can then call goAsync
and run your work right
within the BroadcastReceiver,
which, by the way,
is a super lightweight way
of getting something done.
Note that you aren't guaranteed
to have network or wakelocks.
So there are still many
cases where you should--
DAN GALPIN: Schedule a job
within your BroadcastReceiver
using a WorkManager.
FRED CHUNG: So, if
you have externally
triggered time-sensitive events
that require immediate user
attention, consider
using Firebase Cloud
Messaging to notify your app.
FCM supports high and
normal priority messaging
for high priority messages.
It'll wake the device from doze,
which means that a lot of them
won't be a good thing
for system health.
If the task can run within
less than 10 seconds or so,
you can execute it right away.
Or else schedule a job with--
DAN GALPIN: WorkManager.
There are actually cases
when foreground services
are desired or required.
Ideally, these are
user-initiated tasks
that run for a
long time and want
to supply some sort of
constant update to the user.
Examples are maps,
navigation fitness tracking,
playing music.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN:
In Play Store, we
use a foreground service
when we restore apps
after device set up.
This is OK, because it's
long running work in response
to user interaction.
DAN GALPIN: But it's not as
fun as listening to music.
FRED CHUNG: Some good news is
that these other things are
already impacting your apps.
But perhaps you
haven't noticed yet.
That.
So, in Android N,
new photo broadcasts
no longer happen, but can be
replaced by TriggerContentUris
for jobs, I mean, work.
So, here's what it looks like
using the new WorkManager API.
DAN GALPIN: Now if your app
is running in the background
on an Android O+ device,
the location system service
computes a new location
for your app less often,
even if your app requests
more frequent updates.
Even full Wi-Fi scans are only
performed for background apps
a few times every hour.
So if you're called more often,
the Wi-Fi Manager [INAUDIBLE]
actually just provide
cache results.
Now, if you need to know
when the user reaches
a specific location,
use geofencing.
Now, there are only 100
geofences that can be active.
So if you need more
sites than that,
you can actually use
regional geofences
to swap in and out different
sets of geofences as needed.
Now, that being said--
beacons are awesome-- you can
use the nearby notifications
API.
And that's important,
particularly
if you're a certain
prolific coffee vendor.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: You can
also use the batch version
of the FusedLocationProvider.
Specify a maximum
location update
wait time that is acceptable
for your use case.
And the system will attempt
to batch location updates,
so that your app is
woken up less frequently.
This will optimize battery use.
You can also use
passive location.
That enables your app to
opportunistically piggyback
on other apps' location
updates, up to the fastest
interval specified.
Keep in mind, though, that if
your app's location updates are
tied to any expensive
operations, such as network
calls, you should
throttle those as well.
FRED CHUNG: So, through
batching and passive location,
we can work with location
updates in a power
efficient manner.
Next, let's go through
some related improvements
in the platform.
So, in the past several
releases of Android,
we've introduced a series of
battery optimization features
that are based on deferring and
restricting background tasks.
So you probably are familiar
with some of these already.
For example, a device
could enter doze,
when the device is unplugged,
and when the device isn't
being used for quite some time.
In doze, apps have
to finish any pending
jobs in some periodic
maintenance windows.
DAN GALPIN: On N+, doze is
extended for on the go use
cases, such as when a device is
sitting in the user's pocket.
Now, app standby
was introduced in M,
where it imposes tax
restrictions based
upon app usage.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: And let me tell
you about the brand new stuff.
In Android P,
usage-based restrictions
are applied in a more
fine-grained way.
You may have already learned
about this in the earlier I/O
talk, "Don't Let Your App
Drain Your User's Battery."
Apps will be added to one
of the app's standby buckets
based on usage.
The system applies progressively
more restrictions to your app
as it goes from the
active to the rare bucket.
Additionally, battery
saver is enhanced
in P. It allows users
to have extended
battery life by prioritizing
battery over everything else.
This leads to some
degradation in functionality,
such as location requests,
which are not available
when the screen is off.
However, this mode
is really useful
when you need your device
to last just a bit longer.
FRED CHUNG: So, the features
that we just discussed
have additive impact
on an app's alarms,
jobs, sync, network
access, and FCM messages.
So we really strongly
encourage everyone
to thoroughly test
these scenarios
within your applications.
DAN GALPIN: And the good news is
that there are tools for that.
So, for example,
this ADB command
forces the device into an idle
state, making all apps doze.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: To
test app standby,
first simulate
unplugging the device.
And then you can use the get
and set inactive commands
to get the device in
and out of app standby.
FRED CHUNG: For app
standby buckets,
you can get and set buckets
for a given package using
similar AD commands.
But remember to
simulate unplugging
your device before testing.
There's also framework
APIs available to do that.
Finally, these are commands
for testing battery saver.
One note is that if your
app's UI has a dark theme,
you can consider
enabling the dark theme
when battery saver is turned
on to further to conserve power
on OLED devices.
Through PowerManager,
you can check with an API
and listen to a
broadcast to do that.
DAN GALPIN: So, there
are lots of ways
to make your apps do cool
stuff in the background
without using
foreground services.
Leverage the new
functionality in WorkManager,
use efficient location
strategies, use the new APIs,
and make sure to
tell us what doesn't
meet your needs by
submitting feedback
through the issue tracker.
FRED CHUNG: So, right
after this talk,
you'll probably be busy
updating your target
SDKs, which is all good.
While you are at it,
we strongly encourage
you to check out some selected,
modern features on Android that
are relevant to your use cases.
So you have to add, for
example, notification channels
to your app on O. Otherwise,
well, notifications just won't
show, which won't be good.
Plan your channels carefully, so
that your users can selectively
turn off notifications
that they don't want.
DAN GALPIN: Back
one slide, please.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: On devices
where the Play Store implemented
support for
notification channels,
we see a fewer percentage
of users disabling
all of our notifications.
DAN GALPIN: So if your app is
using a translucent status bar,
you can use the inset
APIs to make sure
that your code doesn't assume
that the status bar is a fixed
size.
Now, if you're using
the navigation drawer,
this is actually really common.
Now if you target
P, you can also
do something interesting
in that cutout area.
Now, public service
announcement,
you don't have to
put your system
image on your only device.
If you haven't used the
emulator in a while,
it's pretty awesome.
Recently, we've added support
for super fast loading,
along with AR support on any
device with a P Developer
Preview system image, you
can simulate DisplayCutout
through the Developer options.
This ends the public
service announcement.
FRED CHUNG: Great.
So, long aspect ratio screens.
So it's become a trend
for OEMs to be shipping
devices like these, with
screens longer than 16
by 9 aspect ratio.
Make sure your apps
immersive experiences
can fully take advantage of
these screen capabilities,
which is pretty awesome.
So, as a last resort, the
system still provides you
a way to declare your maximum
supported aspect ratio.
But it will display a letterbox
around your application
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: And, seriously,
do you really want letterboxes?
DAN GALPIN: With bigger screens
comes more responsibility.
Now, consider taking
advantage of picture
in picture for use cases
such as video chat, movie
playback, fitness
tracking, or Pokemon Go.
Multi-display support
also allows a user
to launch an activity
for your application
on a second display.
And the only thing you have
to really consider here
is it has a second
configuration, which
is going to be different than
the one year app most likely.
So be careful not to make
application-wide assumptions
about hardworking configuration.
And, in conclusion,
Android development
has evolved, to mean using the
latest tools and APIs to enable
better battery life,
smoother multitasking,
supporting the latest hardware
and platform features,
and taking advantage
of Jetpack to build
a modern, testable architecture.
Thank you.
All right.
Actually, no, no, no.
There's actually one more thing.
Android is actually
restricting the use
of some non-SDK interfaces
in Developer Preview 1.
And you saw this,
because we actually
warned you with like
toast and log entries
if these methods were used.
But you'll notice, if
you're testing against DP2,
some of these methods
will just cease to work,
and will cause
your app to crash.
So, please test and
file issues if you
don't think there's
any way your app could
work other than these methods.
And, to help you
out in the future,
we've actually added a new
VM policy for StrictMode
that you can use to turn on
and detect all non-SDK API
usage, which is
really important,
because this non-SDK
usage may actually
be happening in your libraries.
So this is a really great
way to actually make sure
that your app is going to
be compatible going forward.
Because we don't guarantee the
compatibility of any non-SDK
API.
And so that really is it now.
If you haven't been paying
attention in the last 30
minutes, that's OK, because
clearly my jokes need work.
ERIC KUXHAUSEN: If you're
an engineer, hopefully much
of the information shared
today was a review for you.
And we hope you found
the tips useful.
FRED CHUNG: So if you are PM,
and if your app is not quite
targeting 26 just yet, it's not
too late to plan things out,
work with your teams to figure
out how much work is needed.
And, in fact, we
prepared a guide
on Android Developer sites
to help people understand,
based on your current release,
the amount of work needed,
so that we can collectively
push the ecosystem forward.
Thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]